en este vídeo vamos a ver ecuaciones
diferenciales de primer grado pero del
tipo de mujeres homogéneas homogéneas
como cuando decimos que la leche es una
substancia homogénea si la leche es una
sustancia homogénea porque todas sus
partes están bien distribuidas aunque no
sé que tengan que ver la leche con las
ecuaciones diferenciales homogéneas pero
bueno vamos a ver aquí ecuaciones
diferenciales de primer orden homogéneas
y también hay otras ecuaciones
diferenciales que son del tipo homogénea
pero este caso no es igual al otro caso
y bueno en este caso estoy hablando de
las ecuaciones diferenciales homogéneas
de primer orden eso es muy importante
nosotros ya estábamos muy acostumbrados
a ver funciones del estilo derivada de
jett con respecto a x igual a una
función que tenía que ver con xy con
jacques y nosotros vamos a suponer más
bien que no podemos resolver esta
ecuación diferencial ni por el método de
separación de variables ni porque fueran
exactas
y si nosotros quisiéramos resolver esta
ecuación por el método de ecuaciones
diferenciales homogéneas lo que tenemos
que hacer es una sustitución de
variables y después de esta sustitución
de variables la vamos a resolver por
variables separables y sé que tal vez
ustedes no me entiendan bien que es lo
que me estoy refiriendo pero yo si
quiero antes que eso analizar qué es una
ecuación diferencial de primer orden que
sea homogénea bien a lo que me refiero
con esto es que tengamos la derivada de
y con respecto a x y esto va a ser igual
a una función f que depende de y entre x
es decir un cambio de variable y lo que
quiero es que al sustituir este cambio
de variables me queda una ecuación que
sea de variables separables sé que todas
orienta está un poco confuso y no me
entienden muy bien pero vamos a verlo
mejor con un ejemplo cambiamos de color
y pongamos este ejemplo la derivada de
con respecto a x de se me ocurre una
función llamada
x + y todo esto dividido entre x bien
pero qué pasaría si nosotros tratamos de
separar esta ecuación diferencial para
hacerla por variables separables pues yo
no lo veo tan fácil bueno tal vez un
poco pero no es el ejercicio que yo
quiero hacer lo que sí quiero que vean
es que qué va a pasar si esta función
mejor la trató de llevar a una forma de
que entre x pues se podría hacer si
nosotros dividimos x entre x entre x es
decir separamos nuestra división x entre
x + y entre x ésta va a ser ahora
nuestra ecuación diferencial o sea te
lleguen de x es igual a esto pero pues x
entre x es 1 no entonces yo puedo
escribir esto como deje de x igual a x
entre x que es uno más y entre x y aquí
está ya por fin me entre x que era lo
que yo estaba buscando para ejemplificar
mi ecuación diferencial homogénea y
porque estoy dividiendo entre x
bueno mi idea es que voy a hacer un
cambio de variable voy a decir que entre
x es una nueva variable y si yo pongo
aquí una nueva variable entonces me
queda que este lado de la ecuación
diferencial solamente depende de una
sola variable de hecho lo voy a hacer
voy a decir que de amarillo es igual a
entre equis o dicho de otra manera pues
yo puedo decir que ya es igual a b x x
siempre estoy pasando multiplicando a x
del otro lado de una ecuación y esto me
va a servir porque yo lo que quiero es
la derivada de que con respecto a x
ahora ojo voy a suponer que b es una
función que depende también de x
entonces quién va a ser la derivada pues
la derivada de ye con respecto a x es la
derivada de x con respecto a x que es 1
por b o sea que no derivada de x con
respecto de x es 1 y eso lo tengo que
sumar pues la derivada de b con respecto
a x osea x por la derivada de b con
respecto a x lo único que hice fue
derivar una multiplicación de funciones
ahora lo que voy a hacer es sustituir la
derivada de ella con respecto a x en mi
cambio de variable por lo tanto me va a
quedar la derivada de ella con respecto
a x que era de más x x derivada de b con
respecto a x y esto va a ser igual a uno
más entre x pero ya entre x le habíamos
dicho que se llamaba b entonces va a ser
uno más b perfecto y ya que tengo aquí
pues lo primero que me doy cuenta es que
la beta aquí la veda acá la puedo
cancelar entonces va a estar ahí va esta
vámonos y que nos ha quedado nos ha
quedado una ecuación mucho más sencilla
de resolver si yo paso la x del otro
lado pues la puedo pasar dividir vamos a
dividir todo entre x entonces debe con
respecto a x es igual a 1 entre x muy
bien y ahora dicho yo debería de empezar
por aquí si no es que es mucho más fácil
de resolver pero pues vamos a seguir
adelante
yo voy a pasar el de x del otro lado
entonces me va a quedar tve es igual a 1
entre x de x es decir multiplique todo x
de x y ahora si buscamos las primitivas
es decir si integramos de un lado y de
otro que tengo
el integral de la diferencial de bsb y
la integral de 1 / x es logaritmo
natural del valor absoluto de x más una
constante integración no olviden el
valor absoluto de x es muy importante
que no lo olviden bien pero yo ya casi
acabó porque yo sabía cuánto vale b&b
vale y entre x si sustituyó el valor de
b que era entre x pues entonces ya puedo
despejar alguien que realmente era lo
que quería entonces bien entre x es
igual a logaritmo natural del valor
absoluto de x más una constante pero yo
lo que quiero es una función y entonces
es igual a x por el lugar ismo natural
del valor absoluto de x más una
constante bien y aquí está aquí está lo
que nosotros buscábamos una función que
tal que si nosotros sustituimos en
nuestra ecuación diferencial nos da el
resultado x + / jr
cosa que ustedes pueden demostrar en
cualquier momento si ustedes agarran la
función que teníamos acá abajo
en el pizarrón para que la veamos bien
esta función y la derivan entonces no
les va a dar x más que entre x y aquí
está y aquí hay también un pequeño error
porque nosotros no se dieron cuenta que
cuando yo pasé la x multiplicando del
otro lado pues me queda x logaritmo
natural de x del valor absoluto de x más
una constante por x aquí me falta una x
son de sus errores a mateos pero ya
tenemos aquí y es igual a x logaritmo
natural del valor absoluto de x mas x
veces una constante bien pero si ustedes
quisieran saber el valor de la constante
lo que necesitaríamos es una condición
inicial no lo olviden se puede pasar de
una solución general a una particular
con una condición inicial pues en el
siguiente vídeo haremos un par de
ejemplos más así que cuídense y nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo